mercredi soir au birdland un club de
jazz mythique de new york
[Musique]
charlie parker à diana krall en passant
par caen de bézy keith jarrett et michel
petrucciani les plus grands du jazz se
sont produits ici
sur la scène une chanteuse fait sa
dernière répétition avant le spectacle
de ce soir
elle s'appelle myriam fillion roberge ou
plutôt myriam firo et elle chante en
français
[Musique]
la chanson française a toujours été
quelque chose que j'ai adoré depuis le
début fait que ça fait vraiment pas de
moi de l'incorporer à mon répertoire
puis de chanter j'ai fait tellement
plaisir un peu de temps mais normalement
il ya un petit côté nostalgique de la
l'ancien chanson française oui oui je
tenais ma grand mère qui me ramène qui
m'a exposé à des pertes warner celle qui
a déménagé ici il ya dix ans a réussi à
vivre de son art en interprétant
aznavour brel trenet brassens
edith piaf et même alys robi
[Musique]
dépassé par famille de grave dans les
grandes salles de spectacle mais c'est
aussi deux parfois chanté dans des
événements du phare du corporatif amis
club les new-yorkais sont très curieux
il ya beaucoup toutes les différences
qui est exotique en fait d'ailleurs très
multiculturel comme vide parmi ses
musiciens réguliers il y à linus ou
hersh en suisse et le français adrien
chevalier pour eux il n'y a pas de doute
que la chanson française leur permet de
bien vivre à new york
on s'est vite aperçu que justement cette
french touch marché vraiment bien il ya
toujours eu des liens entre l'amérique
et la france et surtout à new york par
exemple à statue de la liberté tout ça
il y avait quand même un lien assez fort
ce que ce soit dans l'art la musique et
la gastronomie est une chose john
valenti propriétaire du bar de l'aisne
depuis plus de 30 ans a toujours eu un
faible pour les artistes francophones
exigent que j'accepte d'une pince à
quelques minutes d'entrer sur scène
la fébrilité est palpable mais c'est
surtout la fierté d'être ici c'est un
rêve
en fait c'est que tous les grands noms
du jazz ont paraphé par bradley ou
pleines devant le public
c'est d'abord la curiosité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais rien n'y fit raw et ses musiciens
veulent maintenant exporter leurs
expériences new yorkaise en france et
dans d'autres états américains
après tout comme le chantait sinatra si
vous réussissez ici vous réussirez
partout ailleurs ici frédéric arnould
radio canada
[Musique]